simple ways man it will be more
acceptable
hold in a post-industrial fabulous
society to develop a socially more
socially oriented project that addresses
mainly people's needs and public spatial
equilibrium in order to achieve the more
I could walk into six city is a very
seldom ask you guys about meet on campus
enough progress to accommodate for the
pool
you
is New York saying wasting
infrastructural water system
how we can revitalize the ground by the
innovation program
New York City revivals historic water
culture and integrate into the urban
fabric how to redesign environmentally
socially and economically and
sustainable food system in light of the
current NYC sustainable initiatives can
constructive wetlands be used to
effectively improve and holster the
wastewater management
how can electronic recycle become an
economic driver neighborhood regenerator
and citywide Alvin rendered Brooklyn
what is the role of urban designers and
influencing the unexpected activities of
informal sectors such as data roots and
government
where do the systems on our site
originate or end can we localize our
waste byproducts and turn them into a
resource off your recycling because they
create a routine
can the negative of the perception of
ways to the altar to the architectural
integration of community initiatives and
small-scale waste is near how can you
sleep system for growing industrial
sector with the track conditions
the benefits from the process in water
implementing ways to waste on this
redirected back to the community with
the system of waste manage will be more
of exactly this possible in a post
industrial capitalist society to develop
is socially more socially oriented
project that addresses mainly people's
needs and public spatial equilibrium in
order to achieve a more equitable and
inclusive City Federal Reserve macias
1x1 visit to campus and west ave coupon
mayonnaise for the pool
you
is New York City wasting and
infrastructural water system
how can revitalize by innovation program
New York City revive its historic water
culture and integrated the urban fabric
how to redesign and mentally especially
and economically and sustainable food
system in light of the current NYC
sustainable initiatives can constructive
weapons be used to effectively improve
and holster the wastewater management
how can electronic recycling become an
economic driver neighborhood regenerator
and City 10
what is the role of urban designers and
influencing the unexpected activities of
informal sectors such as data where sand
dollar
where data systems on our site originate
or end can we localize our waste
byproducts and turn them into a resource
how can recite we become
can the negative of the perception of
ways to the altar to the architectural
integration of community initiatives and
small scale waste is near how can we
slay the system for growing industrial
sector of the track conditions
the benefits from the process in
warrington working lives to waste on
this redirected back to the community
with the system of waste manage will be
more acceptable in a post-industrial to
capitalist society to develop a socially
more socially oriented project that
addresses mainly people's needs and
public spatial equilibrium in order to
achieve a more equitable and inclusive
City when I said early so muscular as
well next one is it program person has
purposefully Department fish for the
pool
his new york state wasting is
infrastructural water system
how we can revitalize the ground by
using mission program
New York City revival historic water
cultured integrated the urban fabric how
to redesign and mentally socially and
economically sustainable food system in
light of the current NYC sustainable
initiatives can constructive wetlands be
used to effectively improve and holster
the wastewater management
how can electronic recycle become an
economic driver neighborhood regenerator
and citywide Alvin in Red Hook Brooklyn
what is the roles are been designers and
influencing the unexpected activities of
informal sectors such as data burst and
government
from the urban design false to do
projects that we've been working on
they've been examples of studio work as
well as questions that we pose to our
self to help focus our projects
throughout the semester so good evening
thank you all for coming my name is
Jeremy Welsh along with my classmates
daniel como cada and off since accom
we'd like to welcome you to the fourth
of five public events curated around the
themes of regional and global waste
streams organized by the students and
faculty of the urban design program and
as a way of introducing our two
distinguished speakers tonight Carlo
raatein and Heather Rogers we wanted to
take this opportunity to also introduce
the larger context in which their
presentation could be understood namely
the design of urban systems and spaces
so to illustrate this we wanted to start
with a space in New York that we're all
familiar with Times Square it's a cliche
of course but it's a useful point of
departure for the following question
which we'd like to pose to you what do
we as designers need to think about when
shaping spaces so of course we're going
to think about the programming of the
space start to think about feck tonics
structure materiality starts to think
about history possibly and then we're
starting to think about larger issues
style aesthetics even if we may not want
to admit it infrastructure energy waste
and health possibly water politics how
the space is going to be used and also
think about economy and finance
communication culture and food we have
social ecology we also have natural
ecology geology and then issues the
region one of the globe so what informs
and affects the spaces of the city's
built environment the list can go on but
we would like to take one item from this
that we as a class are looking at the
semester in our studio projects waste
and briefly and packet to illustrate how
any one of these items on this list can
be further understood and to give an
idea of the multi scalar
multi-dimensional matrix of urban design
on a macro level we can try the impacts
of waste from in within New York City
most of you know that Fresh Kills
landfill and Staten Island now closed is
in the process of becoming a regional
attraction through its transition into a
major part some of you may know that the
landfills that receive our waste now are
located as far away as Ohio Pennsylvania
and Virginia then there's also the scrap
metal and electronics related ways that
are shipped all over the globe to China
India Kenya the carbon emissions from
the freight trucking and shipping of
this waste of course are also another
form of refuse on a micro level one can
map the csos the transfer stations
incinerators recycling plants and
sanitation truck routes in relationship
to their effect on local residents
issues of environmental justice and
health we might even go into the
taxpayer money waste corruption
governmental mismanagement and corporate
fraud
but from the space the trash takes up on
our sidewalks to the loot literally the
mountainous topographical changes it
takes up in our landfills the spatial
impact of New York's waste stream is
expensive and profound the fundamental
disconnect between the perception of
waste and its reality stems at least in
part from our inability to grasp its
spatial impact as we can see in a
typical life in New York trash bag
finally from the historical perspective
we can see how New York's ability or
failure to deal with waste had a direct
impact in shaping the city for example
the famous 1811 commissioners plan laid
out in a grid iron which maximize real
estate profitability but accommodated no
alleys cementing the place the curbside
trash bag as we just saw in 1842 the
Croton Aqueduct is constructed to bring
fresh water to New York from upstate
this actually had an adverse effect
raising the water table with the
drilling of less wells and causing
flooding and basement units this brought
to light the problems of water-borne
illness and social injustice related to
time and housing so then in 1878 the
first architectural competition for
design of tenements in New York was
funded by the plumbers Union to generate
the market demands for proper sewage
systems in indoor water closets the
plumbers achieved with the governmental
in social agencies could not the 1919
the fill that was result of the
construction of the Lexington Avenue
subway tunnel was not waste rather the
dirt was used to double the size of
governors island in the 1975 Rosado
Island was fitted with a pneumatic tube
system for its garbage changing how
waste was perceived brother
of that island and of other cities that
have implemented similar systems
throughout Europe kanesha and in 2001
New York's only landfill Fresh Kills was
closed resulting in waste being shipped
throughout the u.s. as was discussed
plans are currently underway as we know
for the redevelopment enter large part
and in 20-30 with the mayor's new plan
the way waste moves throughout the city
will be changed for the economic rida
vision redistribution of water and
land-based waste transfer stations with
this reduced redistribution the movement
of waste will become more efficient and
equal throughout the city the history of
what forces shape the city of course
it's also a history of how and how we go
about implementing our ideas today
increasingly it is our responsibility
not only to design a final product but
to design the very processes by which
our designers can be implemented so
urban design is not limited to
Architecture planning is not bounded by
fixed property lines or large-scale
physical transformations the task of
urban design is to operate across a
multitude of scale simultaneously from
the global geopolitical and economic
systems we participate in to the
intimate interiors of the spaces we live
in from the geological strata that
cities sit on to the paving patterns
that we all walk on it's designing
projects but it's also designing
processings it's the design of spaces
but also systems the design of solutions
but also of positions perceptions and
questions this at least in part is the
ongoing pedagogical experiment of the
urban design program here at GCF this
semester our studio is contributing to
this experiment in two ways first by
expanding the field of the urban
the regional and second by bringing in a
specific orientation to the studio by
focusing on weights in other words
infrastructure and impact are now as
much of the designers responsibility as
forums base and materials we see this as
a new approach exploring responsibility
I'm sorry exploring what remains
unexamined by the more traditional
professions of architecture and planning
as our speakers tonight will illustrate
these are not issues that require
conventional problem-solving they
require radical and fundamental
rethinking this is precisely the
proactive role that urban design must
take the critical reimagine ation of the
city so tonight we'll be hearing from
Carlo writing and Heather Rogers and
their insights into these broad and
critically important issues to introduce
these speakers i would like to deduce
stanka tonight we're very happy to have
with us two speakers whose work deals
precisely with this question of
reimagining the city both of them have
worked extensively in the respective
fields researching new realms of
possibilities for both the built-in
social fabric of our cities our first
speaker tonight is Heather Rogers
Heather's a journalist and author whose
work has been published in The New York
Times Magazine mother Jones and the
nation her first book gone tomorrow the
hidden life of garbage received the
editors choice distinction from the New
York Times Book Review and nonfiction
choice from the Guardian her documentary
film also titled dawn tomorrow a screen
and film festivals worldwide the latest
book Green gone wrong how our economy is
undermining the environmental revolution
examines popular market-based solutions
ecological destruction she has spoken
internationally on the environmental
effects of mass consumption and is
currently a senior
hello the progressive think tank demos
our second speaker tonight is Carla
Roddy Carlo is an architect and engineer
and a partner of Carla Roddy associati
an architecture firm based in Torino
Italy he is also the director of the
sensible city lab at MIT he has
presented his work at the kuntz tall
grass venice biennale the international
exhibition in zaragoza spain in Milan's
Fashion Week in the moma here in New
York and also at the design museum in
Barcelona he holds an engineering degree
from the akola nacional de pinet shall
say as well as politecnico di Torino the
masters of philosophy and PhD from the
University of Cambridge and moved to MIT
in two thousand is a Fulbright
postdoctoral fellow please join me in
welcoming both of them here tonight
hi I'm actually going to give carlos
okay I don't see it here but if I just
oh here
ok
thank you so much for coming and thanks
a lot to the GSAT program for bringing
me here it's a pleasure to be here and I
think that the work that you guys are
doing is fascinating is great to see
your presentation I spoke with with the
group with the class at the beginning of
the semester so it's it's pretty great
to see the discussion and the ideas
evolved over that time so I look forward
to the discussion and to hear and Carlo
it's nice to share the podium with him
so I am going to talk how many of you
are at the first taught that I did about
garbage so the sense okay I'm going to
repeat a few things that I talked about
then and then I'm going to talk about
some concrete solutions that are
happening today so much of what when we
talk about environmental sustainability
and when we talk about how to reduce
waste and in whatever form that is
garbage or energy or materials you know
raw material use or corruption we often
are told that the technology we need
just isn't there yet and we're often
told that we need to study it more we
need to research it more and part of
what I want to talk about tonight is
that we do have a lot of what we need
and it is being used and there are some
barriers in the united states that i
think are really important to not only
be aware of but also to start really
challenging and so just to reiterate
some some things about sort of key
aspects of garbage each american throws
out about four and a half pounds of
garbage a day which is kind of
staggering the you know there's only
five percent of the world's population
in the united states but we consume
about a quarter of all its resources 20
twenty-five percent of its resources and
we produce it's hard to know but about
that much of its waste the economic
level and the level of waste are usually
matching you know they usually match one
another the amount of trash that we
threw out in the United States is
doubled over the last it's more than
doubled over the last 30 years you're a
lot of corporations and some politicians
talking about how much energy of how
much more energy efficient production is
how much more energy efficient
electronics are these you know how much
more efficient various kinds of
machinery is all of that's true it and
yet we have more and more pollution more
and more garbage more and more other
kinds of you know co2 emissions so why
is that and something that I talk about
a lot in my new book is that it's it's
linked to the very underpinnings of our
economic system which relies on growth
and that growth comes from very specific
places it comes from nature and it comes
from the mass production of raw
materials into commodities the mass
consumption of those commodities and the
wasting of those commodities so that the
process can start again and as long as
our as long as our economy and our
well-being is predicated on that we're
going to continue no matter how
efficient we get we're going to continue
producing ever more waste ever more co2
emissions and in economics it's called
the Jevons paradox the more energy you
save
use within a capitalist framework at
this point the way that capitalism works
at this point so um a couple of your
things about garbage the you know a lot
of people will say recycling is a good
idea recycling you know if we can just
use the first reduce reuse recycle which
was coined in the 1970s with the rise of
the environmental movement and when
people say that phrase mostly they just
mean recycling and there's the reduce in
the reuse part that sort of fall to the
wayside because those aren't compatible
with expanding consumption if you reduce
consumption that means you're not buying
as much if you reuse that means you're
repairing the television you're
repairing the laptop computer you're
repairing the cell phone you know and
and then you know people aren't buying
new ones and that really puts a dent in
economic growth so recycling you know
we're talking about like household
garbage and garbage from commercial
businesses and offices and apartment
buildings in New York City and in the
region and when people when individuals
recycle it's really important it's
important it matters I recycle but it's
important for us to understand that it
only plays a very small role in
addressing the kind of scope and the you
know the intensity and toxicity of the
waste that we're dealing with and and if
you know if we keep it in perspective if
we're realistic about it you know yes
but a lot of people sort of stop there
and it's very common in our culture for
it you know and people now bring their
tote bags to the grocery store and yes
that's great what does it mean you know
not a whole lot I mean it's a good
symbol but it's not a whole lot more
than that so what is effective what is
working one of the places that I went
for my new book is fri bird which is in
the southwest of germany and it's a town
that has to eco communities they're
essentially neighborhoods as anybody
been to freiburg anybody here yeah a
couple um did you get to go to I went
through these two neighbor the two
neighborhoods once called Baba and the
other one's called weasel felt that
either we go to those know so freiburg
is a college town it's an old town it
was founded in 1120 and the economy now
primarily is tourism but they have
fashioned themselves into an
environmental kind of Haven there it's
considered one of the greenest cities in
the world and I went because I wanted to
see what's it like you know how does it
work and as I'm sure a lot of you know I
mean you look at some of the green
buildings in New York City and they're
really expensive like the soul air which
is down in Battery Park City it's um the
rent and not that place it's like you
know this high-rise condo building and
it has solar panels and like you know
they did all this cool stuff where they
recirculate water you know they use the
gray water and they you know did all
this sort of efficient you know
insulation and and whatever anyway
they've done a lot of cool stuff the
rents start at like thirty five hundred
dollars a month for a studio and they go
up to ten thousand dollars a month for
rent so you know there's that or you
could go to like New Mexico and how
dirt into tires and you know build your
earth ship and you know about the grid
which is cool if that's what you want to
do but a lot of people don't want to
live that way and they see when you say
you know adopting a lifestyle where you
consume less energy where you consume
fewer resources in general where you
drive less that in the United States is
verboten like if you start talking about
that people start to freak out you know
it's like you're attacking our freedom
like you're telling us that we can't do
stuff and something I wanted to find out
is you know can we can we consume less
and maintain a really good standard of
living and you know of course we can so
and without having to you know go it's
the middle of nowhere and without having
to pay ten thousand dollars a month for
rent so boba has these two communities
they've been around for over a dozen
years so they have a track record there
they you know they're not like new
fly-by-night flash in the pan I
developments there's over 15,000 people
that live in both of these neighborhoods
and they are mixed income so there's
really there's a lot of components to it
that I think are really useful and
looking at what could work and how it
could work so this is Baba one of the
neighborhoods and boba was started by
the people who live there it's a
grassroots bottom-up development and it
started in the mid-1990s and I'm just
going to
you so you can see in the back that
yellow that big yellow building that's
an army barracks that the it was a
French military base that was
decommissioned in the early 90s and
reverted ownership reverted to the city
and there was a housing crisis at the
time and the city was talking to
developers about going in and just
building you know a bunch of doing a big
commercial development and a group of
kind of bohemian independent scientists
and engineers and you know designers and
artists got together and college
professors got together and they said no
we want to make an environmentally
sustainable community and they convinced
the city to sell them some of the
barracks buildings and they retrofitted
them and in doing that they realized
that they could build a bigger they
could take the whole that they could
take the whole base and build you know
build an entire community there so they
started doing a study and I will show
you I'll tell them more that story about
a show you some pictures so one of the
one of the ideas so what they did was
they started having meetings and these
meetings were open to the public once a
week they got a big grant from the
German government to come up with an
urban design and urban plan for this
neighborhood so I started having you
know weekly meetings it was very like a
meaningful participatory process it
wasn't it wasn't just you know we're
having one meaning one meeting at like
you know 7am for 15 minutes on a Sunday
morning you know be there and if you're
not there then that's it
going to say that we met with
stakeholders so there was a meaningful
process of collaboration that went on
and one of the things that they came up
with was no single-family houses are
allowed and um you know basically this
is a suburb of Freiburg and there are
single-family houses in Freiburg so it
was a decision you know this is much
more material efficient and energy
efficient and and it's much yeah and so
that that that was one of the big I just
want to show you a little bit I these
are my pictures um you know they're not
the greatest but I went there in
February and it was snowing and cold and
I rented an apartment in vivanta stay
there for five days which I will tell
you a little bit about but so this is
just to give you a sense of the streets
and here this is the kind of main plaza
or I'm from Texas and we call it a plaza
but um like square and there is a
farmers market in the middle of a
snowstorm and everyone's riding their
bikes in the middle of the snowstorm but
um so this town square was something
that I really want to impress upon you
is that boba was started you know
basically 15 years ago and they are
still engaged in a process you know one
of the things that I really walked away
from this understanding in a way that I
had before was that getting to greater
environmental sustainability is a
process it's not a product that we can
buy so the process that they're engaged
in was you know starting out with making
this plan and then carrying out that
plan in
that plan the entire base they were just
finishing it the entire development when
I was there so it's basically done it's
basically full so there's that aspect of
it being an ongoing process but then
also the urban design is an ongoing
process this is an organic thing it's
not done that you know okay now we can
walk away the people who live there
continue to participate and you know to
different degrees it just depends on
what you're what you want to do but this
public square the city wanted to put the
public square somewhere else and there's
a barracks building facing this square
and that became the kind of you know
community center of BOE bomb and the
city wouldn't recognize that and they
built a square you know not that far
away like you know four hundred yards
away but but it was totally awkwardly
oriented and not in you know where
people would use it so they fought
really hard and they finally got the
city to let them you know who's owned
this for the farmers market and to have
the square to have you know community
gatherings there and some other things
so you know just as a demonstration this
is something that you know kind of all
all these steps freiburg is famous for
being a big green party stronghold you
know sort of dealing with city council
people who are green party and all a lot
of them support what you know the
general idea of what they're doing but
still you know there's the bureaucratic
details that are always I mean those are
such a big part of this of how to make
these changes I don't have to tell you
guys to sure you know I was just
recently in Minnesota doing some talks
there and I was a Winona State and um I
was on a panel with this guy who was in
charge of the sustainability program at
University they're doing this whole kind
of makeover and he is an engineer and
one of the students said why can't we
make the university run on wind power
because there's good wind in that part
of Minnesota and who said the technology
isn't there and I was like really and he
was yeah and I said what what technology
isn't there and he said well the
technology isn't there it's just the
zoning I was like okay what's the zoning
problem he was like it's not that it's
just that we you know whatever so it
went on like that and finally it got
down to you know it was really just a
bureaucratic internal University thing
that he didn't want to deal with you
know so it's like if we can start
getting in there it's tedious it's
boring but you know the technology the
technology is there so all right okay so
this is um there's several clusters of
houses in BO bomb like I said they're
off they're all multifamily this one is
called the solar settlement and it's
fine art architect named Ralph dish
who's a tremendous architect and he the
way that these are designed is they use
passive house technology which many of
you probably know and they are what
these calls the plus energy houses so
they produce more energy than they use
and the way that they do that is it's
hard to see because it's covered with
snow but the entire roof of these
structures is made of solar panels so
the way that you know you can't always
rely on the Sun and this is something
else that people always talk about you
know we can't use solar because there's
not
the Sun isn't always shining we can't
use when when turbines because the wind
isn't always blowing of course it's not
so you make a hybrid system and that's
what they've done in info bond solar
panels wind and then they use natural
gas to create heat and electricity when
those two aren't working they also use
biomass they use wood waste that they
there's a lot there in the Black Forest
so there's a lot of wood waste from
logging that goes on there and they
insist that it's sustainable logging and
so you know if that brings up a lot of
questions about regulation that are
really important but but so that's what
you know they have this mix and
something also that encourages currently
Germany gets jumped the country has been
influenced by what's going on in fiber
and currently the kinds of innovations
that are being actualized in Freiburg
are are you know very encouraging for
the rest of the country and as of 2008
Germany got about fifteen percent of its
power of its electricity from renewable
sources and it's on target to double
that in the next decade so the type of
development that that we see here is you
know on on track to become more and more
common the one of the ways that you know
again this gets at the bureaucratic kind
of policy changes that could happen
Germany enacted a law the layman's term
for it is the feed-in tariffs and the
way that it works is you know the idea
is to incentivize people to use
renewable energy wind solar geothermal
and if you use those kinds of if you use
you install those kinds of systems or
you know what's happening in freiburg is
you know a group of people get together
and invest in a wind farm the way that
you do the way that you you know the big
problem is the capital cost the upfront
you know essentially you're paying for
your energy up front with coal and gas
we pay for it slowly like in
installments but with with renewable
energy you have to pay those costs up
front and that becomes a really serious
barrier so what the german government
has done is they've enacted a policy the
feed-in tariff which says that everyone
who gets electricity from the grid all
the rate payers pay 10 cent more per
kilowatt hour that money goes into a
pool to pay people who install solar
panels and windmills and the like that
goes to a pool of money that pays them
double the rate that they pay for
electricity so if you install solar
panels you can sell your electricity to
the utility and they have to buy it from
you at double the rate that you you know
double the going rate for electricity
and they have to do that for 20 years
and that means that you can pay off your
investment in seven or eight years so
you get about you know 12 or 13 years of
profit so this has led to one in every
hundred houses in Germany installing
solar panels so that's another just
example very practical you know and and
it's you know it's sort of everybody
like chipping in so there's a number of
components that that comprise a passive
house technology one of them this is
actually inside one of the buildings in
in the dish development and the events
up top are part of a heat exchange a
heat exchanger ventilation system so
there's just key components heat
exchanger Bentley
system this is a super thick door and
you can see it's about it's about five
inches thick or so triple pane argon gas
between the panes and there's all this
technical stuff the heat exchanger
ventilation system is like a honeycomb
system so much heat is lost out of
buildings because in the ventilate in
the ventilation of the buildings the hot
air just goes out and the cold air comes
in and the heat exchanger retains ninety
percent of the heat so there's all kinds
of the sort of technical stuff why this
stuff matters you know this kind of this
kind of insulation you know the walls
are very thick they have a lot of
insulation all the parts of the houses
in a passive house are are made and fit
really tightly so that it's very well
insulated and then you have this kind of
ventilation system that's very energy
efficient so you get fresh air but you
don't lose the heat all of these things
come together to make a structure that
uses about 1 15th the energy of a
standard house so it amounts to a
tremendous save savings and in the
United States fifty six percent of all
the energy we use goes toward heating
and cooling houses of buildings in
Germany it's about three-quarters so
this is a big deal doing this kind of
stuff is a big deal now this is the
buildings that onion involve our new
buildings almost all of them are new
buildings so just to keep it in
perspective ninety percent of all the
buildings of the United States are not
new and most of the buildings are not
going to be new you know we have to deal
with the existing structures that we
have so retrofitting is really key part
and I don't get into that but I just
want to stress how important that is
this is the inside of the apart of one
of the apartments and you can see you
know it looks just like you know a
normal apartment it's not it you know
it's very like I stayed in an apartment
and I didn't notice
a difference except it was actually more
comfortable because it was the
temperature was consistent and this is a
kitchen and you can see up just to the
left of the the light on the chandelier
that's a heat exchanger in this house
the other one was a more industrial
version and this is the it's very you
know it looks just like a regular bed ok
some other aspects of what goes on in
faux pas are the corrugated structure is
a bicycle ok I'm going to talk about a
couple things here but one is the waist
there's compost recycling and then
garbage so they separate their garbage
like that and then there's just going to
talk about the system like seeing the
neighborhood as a as a system so they
you can see the sort of pattern in the
concrete those are just like drainage
channels to catch rain water so they do
this whole rain water retention system
some of the structures are required to
have sedum on the roofs and that you
know is all is a lot of I mean I think a
lot of you know how good of an idea that
is and and then there's parts everywhere
so it was really like the way that the
place was designed was not only the
specific kind of architecture but then
you know they pulled back and they said
okay wait how do we want the rest of
this place to function what are the
social aspects you know it's not just
you know the technical stuff you know
it's also how we occupy the space and
how we interact with each other in the
neighborhood and the social engagement
that we have with ourselves and with the
environment how do we move around so the
transportation issues
parks became very important there's
another part parks and playgrounds they
built the playgrounds with a lot of the
kids and and then of course you know
this is um on on all the streets and it
says two cars that children and
pedestrians get the right of way like no
matter what and then you can see here
that all the bicycles parked out front
so every apartment part of that they
came up with what they call the transfer
their transportation concept and they
came up with this when they first did
the plan of vivant and one of the
aspects of the the transportation
concept was every building has to have a
shed for bicycles it has to have bicycle
parking out front easily accessible
plenty of space and so they all do and
they also said we need really good mass
transit there was no mass transit at the
time again they had to really wrangle
with the city to get tramline a tram
line run out there and it takes about
you know 10 or 15 minutes to get to the
city center and it's very efficient so
you know like I said again it's this
process of engagement and it wasn't easy
but it happened and you can also see
here more of the multi-family houses now
another key part of the traffic concept
was that no cars are allowed on a
neighborhood streets you can park and
unload and then you have to move your
car you cannot leave it and the idea was
that and you have to park it even the
man man takes a bike you have to park it
there to parking garages on either end
of the neighborhood and if you want to
have a car you have to park it there and
it's you know might be like a 15 minute
walk to your house and you have to buy a
space in the parking garage and a space
cost twenty four thousand dollars so if
you
have a car you've really got to want to
have a car and people choose to live in
fo bomb the neighborhood all the units
are full almost all the units were full
when i was there and the rate of
automobile use there is half of what it
is in the rest of germany so people want
to not have cars you know and there's
there's this idea in the united states
that well you know people want cars they
don't want mass transit that's why we
give them cars and actually you know I
want really good mass transit and I'm
lucky to live in New York City but when
i lived in other places I couldn't have
it so the market doesn't always deliver
yeah you could talk more about that
later but um so this has been very
effective and the city again has fought
them tooth and nail over this car thing
they don't like it one bit and you know
for various reasons but and and i was
there when i was there a few days after
that a group of people from baba it's
called forum go bomb that is the kind of
organization the community organization
they were going to City Hall to meet
again to defend this car traffic concept
and then one of the things that they do
have is they have a you know mass
transit bicycle paths pedestrian they
fade you know they prioritize all that
anime they develop their own really
efficient car sharing program so the
this is one of the cars in the car
sharing it's like kind of zipcar type of
thing but easier and and tons of people
use it and then I'm just going to talk
quickly about the energy where they get
their energy and like I said they use
that this is the main power plant for
the neighborhood so they built their own
power plant it runs on biomass which
they get from sawmills and it's wood
chips
and it's a combined heat and power plant
so what they do is they normally in a
typical power plant what they do is they
generate electricity and then all of the
heat that comes out of that generation
of electricity is lost that's what the
cooling towers are for and what a
combined heat and power plant does is it
captures that heat and it sends it to
the houses or the buildings nearby so
you get this kind of you you get up from
about forty percent efficiency energy
efficiency up to about eighty percent
energy efficiency to driven that
dramatic shift one of the reasons why
some utilities don't like it is that you
have to have a smaller facility and you
have to in order to to do the
distributed heat it's also called
distributed power and heat so because
you have to run lines to the buildings
around to take advantage of that heat
that you capture so that's the kind of
system that they put in and these are
the woodchips being burned that's just
inside the plant this is another passive
house this is one of the first passive
house multi-family homes ever built and
this this building is not hooked up to
that power plant it has its own power
plant in the basement and it runs on
natural gas which it gets from the
Ukraine which gets it from Russia but
they anyway they have it's a combined
heat and power system within their own
building so they heat the heat water to
to distribute heat around it generates
electricity and the heat water to
distribute around the building and it's
kept in these this is the insulation and
these heavily insulated tanks so and
then also on top of this building
panels so there's this incredible amount
of efficiency that is created and you
know one of the things that again
getting back to the social aspect of
this is that these kinds of I mean I
feel like I've seen so many pictures of
solar panels on buildings and windmills
on hillsides and all that stuff and it's
equi is it you know why don't we have it
yet what the hell was going on and one
of the things that I found in in
Freiburg was that there's this whole
process of social engagement this whole
process of the people in boba
understanding themselves as political
actors and as agents in creating their
community and there was a number of you
know I don't think that just comes out
of nowhere and I think a lot of people
get frustrated they're like why aren't
people doing more you know and and it's
just hard to know how to get people
motivated a lot of what the
environmental movement does and has done
for 34 years is try to scare people you
know like appeal to that emotional you
know the fear and and I think that there
are a lot of very terrifying things
happening global warming is happening
it's not something that's going to
happen people are dying and drowning and
ecosystems are you know species are
going extinct you know I don't have to
tell you the whole terrible story but
there's just a sequence of events that
happened in and around freiburg that i
think is helpful at decoding how
something like this could happen and
i'll just run through it quickly in the
1975 a the state wanted to build a
nuclear power plant about 30 kilometers
outside of freiburg and it was one of
the world's largest light water reactor
plants
the people in freiburg got really
worried about it and the farmers in the
countryside around where they were going
to build the power plant we're very
worried about how it was going to affect
their crops and farmers have been very
conservative and of course the freiburg
was very much in university town at that
point and at that point many of you
remember was pretty pretty radical time
politically especially in germany and
but they came together and it was sort
of unprecedented and they occupied the
site where the nuclear power plant was
slated to be built 30,000 people came
the occupation lasted for over a year
and a half and they built an encampment
and they built a school to teach
political for like political education
and one of the people that was there was
Ralph dish and he after going through
that experience he said you know I we
need to do something about it and he
became an architect to it he calls
himself like the solar architect a
number of other people in Freiburg also
came out of this protest and one of the
institutions it became you know it just
gained momentum from there there's the
Fraunhofer Institute which is one of the
world's leading solar research centers
is there there's a company called solar
fabric they make solar panels and the
people that on that were at those
protests so they played a really key
role and then in the toward the end of
the 1970s if the establishment of the
Green Party and that happens in the
region around Freiburg and in nineteen
eighty nineteen eighty-six another
really decisive moment hits and that's
the Chernobyl nuclear meltdown and you
know over I think it was over a hundred
thousand people were displaced and and
many people died and what happened in
the aftermath was that a radioactive
cloud moved over Europe and hung
europe for a long time i think over a
year and it hung over freiburg and i met
some people i met this woman who had
young children at the time and she said
that you know she formed group you know
people form groups to go travel to get
food because they didn't want to drink
the milk they didn't want their children
to eat the crops that were grown there
and so they would form these committees
and go and get food to eat I mean they
were terrified and something else that
sort of fits into this picture is that
during World War two fiber was heavily
bombed and and when that same woman that
I talked to she's a retired grandmother
she told me that when she was a kid was
67 years old she told me when she was a
kid she remembers Freiburg being
destroyed and so there's this memory
right and this kind of generational and
in the generation that's still there of
destruction of what it could actually be
like you know so i think that when
chernobyl happened it really touched
that nerve and in response to that the
the german government set up a
Environmental Protection ministry and
the name is something like the
environmental protection and nuclear
safety ministry it was like a big deal
and and then when the Green Party you
know the green party continued gaining
momentum and and formed a coalition
government in two thousand and at that
time the government decided to they
created a law that said that Germany
would get off of nuclear power entirely
by 2020 you know so there was there's
been a lot of you know if there's this
sort of trickle up you know from the
grassroots and and then that gains
momentum and you know comes back in the
form of the feed-in tariff and this type
of thing unfortunately Angela Merkel
wants to is already relicensing nuclear
power plants to continue operating
beyond 2020 and months to get rid of
that so as I said these things are
ongoing battles but that's it thanks
yeah good evening everybody it's a
pleasure to be here thanks thanks all
for coming I am going to talk a bit
about waist and a 4gb flash drive but
more generally you know we discussed
before trying to look at how
technologies they allow us to design
understand malignancies in energy way
and this is what we are doing in two
places mostly the sensible still a bin
MIT in Boston in some of the projects at
the end you'll see a done in
collaboration with the office that's
camera at the beginning so you know let
me tell you what you do at the lab so
you can look at this picture that's
something that people used to be really
fascinated in the 1990s I think about
the work it becomes more and more
virtual so 90 90 90 93 is when the first
browser was developed it was called
mosaic before internet explorer and
mozilla all of that 1995 is when
Nicholas Negroponte about being digital
so people thought you know that our
world will become super sure that cities
in space we disappear that's George
Gilder in 90 95 the road we are headed
for the data cities you know because of
all this personal computing in the
digital blah blah cities are leftover
baggage from industrial you know it's a
tough job to be a futurologist
especially somebody goes back and sees
what you or you say 15 years ago because
no prediction could be more wrong you
know we know the story now that's a
picture from ken gene from last year
chan itself is planning to build more
urban fabric than all of humanity ever
killed we also know that since 2008 now
half of the words
cities according to the UN this was well
almost five business like 20 30 so what
happened is that actually the digit of
that geezer was talking about what you
see here and digital layers didn't
really kill physical space a certain
sense the digital in the physical
recombining in creating incredible new
potential for the way we understand
cities we live in cities a most
important for all up all of us design in
change cities and we say this perhaps is
like almost like a type of new planets
people in city and technology and if you
look at that is a new discipline people
in cities what we've been doing in the
past as architects and planners people
in space I could be people in
technologies work places like the Media
Lab at MIT and many other universities
have been doing people in technology but
we combine the three other musical you
interface then looks at digital and
physical combining bits and atoms with
centaurs lurching becoming one and
you're certain sense i believe it's a
very similar time today the same time
when 9023 almost hundred years ago
Corbusier was writing machine
civilization is looking for it needs to
find its architectural expression well
today is exactly something just change
machine
the digital biotech nanotech inside so
we are exactly the same phone more type
architecture expression with that we
interface with the space we have outside
outside of yourself can we now redesign
because of the new technology that means
this is what we are looking after the
same cebu city lab now i will start with
the project gives me brush and then we
waste and then move to other projects
also related to sustainability some of
the great things that ever shot before
about mobility and how we can actually
be used emissions and improve efficiency
losses well so the project we prolly
trance track it was in seattle in New
York it was exhibited at the
architecture lead here in New York last
year and he started with a very simple
consideration now if you take this
computer in computer you know for this
computer you know every single chip
white was produced how to move across
the planet how you became this computer
every single chip in you see there a map
it snapped by the naruto punani for the
site works at both stores map so every
single chick you know here it came from
china with a one ended up in singapore
this stuff with the cupertino came to
your desk you know everything for every
unit now a few years when you throw this
away i feel you don't know anything
anymore about so you know so in other
terms the problem is the following the
global supply chain is very well
know everything about it for the global
removal chain what happened to start in
Detroit away Anderson very very little
and you know if just waistline joined
plants in the world it's in Baltimore
and you have a look at the information
you have there how you know the most
sophisticated waste management plans you
know how little knowledge there is about
what's happening there in different
different elements you know the point is
that all the knowledge all the
technology that transform the global
supply chain over the past few decades
has a really active yet click know about
remover check so we said well what if we
could actually put little tags on
toothbrush and then put in the trash and
follow that to the waste collection
waste transportation see where it
fashions up it is shipped where it goes
if it goes to dump it is incinerated is
recycled what if you could do something
like a little bit like what they do to
you when you go to hospital you keep it
fresher in your blood in a big follow
the back to the body you know return
from sending the fabric
so could we do the same thing at the
scale of the city in order to better
understand the system and you know
there's major problems there for
instance it in some cases not really
from the United States but especially
from from some countries in Europe
rather low key ways / to developing
countries ended up where it shouldn't
end up being treated nothing as it
should be pretty so there's there's main
global issues that happen today the
waste removal so the question is it what
can we have to be better understand the
system by using slowly the top well the
first thing we had to design it that
there is no time you can get off the
shelf so we have to design this is like
a small cell phone you can refuse GPS
because inside attract you don't have
you cannot get your position who GPS so
it uses an address system that's about
fingerprint thing it's a bit similar to
what the old iphone I convolution one
used to do you have to design this was a
person will seem quite big then you have
to miniaturize it make a much much
smaller but that has not something else
out in fact this later is if you really
want to solve tomorrow's urban issues
would you put together many disciplines
anything from sociologist physicist
mathematician
designers in this case the only way to
do this was by having a team at them at
your people who actually were able to
design a few months just equivalent for
a small sample then we had to to get to
identify objects track this was actually
in Seattle we send out an announcement
what was very impressive was how many
people came in that fashion you know
we're doing this again actually here but
those of the beautiful seattle public
library by frame philosopher or if you
know it is beautiful sleek building and
without an announcement in the following
day had hundreds of people with all this
garbage change old washing machines and
addressed a family right the people that
I be freaked out a little bit but in
which was incredible how much people
care about you know the fact is that our
stuff when we throw it away dozens of
that doesn't is appear it's a still go
somewhere and so we don't fascinate
about where does it go we don't know we
throw it away and this is a way to find
out well the other thing way to cover
this develop different materials use
some tests you know in order to make
this stronger not so if you put just a
tag into the waste removal straight
crash so whatever materials we use it
here some Testament here and then recent
ask in Boston just to see the system how
it work you can see actually a starbuck
cup and if you gather components moving
from Cambridge
we eat away
cardboard actually went there and then
ended up in the ship and went to cycle
and you know of course they would want
to do is when you had more many of them
you can actually look at life he weighs
so you can see how different type
different waste streams in this case all
the electronics anyone can you also
easily if you use a street view or
simple Google we've actually following
look at the kind of the master our
everyday object so i'll show you not for
the first time
you
and we're still working on their own the
results you can see the updates on our
sites like fast track but there's a lot
very interesting things coming out of
the analysis one of the things for
instance is how much we could optimize
the system the way we move all the trash
you know if you if you look it's a few
matters potted if you see how some staff
went from seattle to baja california in
some time when sprayed and other stuff
with all the way to Chicago and then
went down so how we could actually
princess save of co2 just by optimizing
the removal the white flashes you move
in the number of other very interesting
parameters are coming out of this that
surprisingly nobody we had detected
before because it was no knowledge of
the system so this is I want to start
with this as it no it is really with
work Jeremy never showed I had shown
before in some other cases well we need
to go and try to use technology to solve
some of the pollution or the problems
that we chose elsewhere this approach we
presented the venice biennale here pour
ce soir and we are now working on a
second prototype but i'll show you
briefly the concert well the concept is
like you're familiar with happening the
Gulf the tragedy in the Gulf your hoped
it will not happen again but if you look
at what happened there there's a few
lessons to learn and for instance one
interesting thing is that at one point
during the summer they were up to 800
schemers so ships trying to clean the
soft surface of the water
there and you know they work in
different ways but this pilot all the
skimmers collected only people sign of
the old get water on the surface of the
earth and the reason for that is that
you know it's very difficult to do to do
this you know the previous life the
reason for that is is very difficult to
to do this with big vessels collect
water and oil in the separate deal and
then take this back to the cows and then
cross it over there so our question was
can you actually something else
designing think about the kind of storm
approach to solve the problem if you
design little things with the problems
of the move autonomously collector on
energy from the environment and cookies
energy clean up the surface of the water
and the interesting thing is that at MIT
a few years ago a couple of years ago in
a turkey develop this nano material it
actually sector is able to separate all
from the water in a very effective way
so its hydrophobic so it doesn't get any
water but lets the daughter or so
happens so the question is could you do
something like that could be think about
very little units that would move on to
the surface of the water and then
self-organized you know have a swarm
behavior and then absorb the oil dispose
it lawfully either by burning it or by
leaving in two pockets that can be
the later stage and then people doing
this is a constant so that was our our
thinking our challenge in the BB and
that's how we came up with the with this
puzzle small inexpensive scalable and
self-organizing given unit that would
work in at this slowly moved in a
synchronized way this was our first
prototype it was all made we see this is
tested in in one word times at MIT and
give was actually the second prototype
I've been built the one-headed event is
being added probably photo takes it gets
all its energy from the environment you
could actually get games you from the
oil itself but then you end up in the
problem that when Oh water is clean you
don't have anything in any source of
energy anymore such it is better to get
it from the Sun in here it is in the
charts and I'll show you quick video
following the 2010 Deepwater Horizon
League and estimated five million
barrels of oil spread into the Gulf of
Mexico in order to remove the oil of the
surface of the ocean over 800 skimmers
were deployed however these vessels were
only capable of collecting every percent
of the overall surface spill due to
challenges of operation and scalability
what if we could design a small
inexpensive scalable self-organizing
skimmer that would operate autonomously
to corral absorb and process the oil on
site using a breakthrough nano
technology developed at MIT it is now
possible to easily separate oil from
water a new nano fabric selectively
absorb large quantities of hydrophobic
liquids like oil without collecting any
water by heating of the material the oil
can then be removed and the Nano fabric
can be used over and over again with
constant absorption imagine we can use
this nano material on the surface of the
ocean like a paper towel gliding along
the water sea swarm is a fleet of
autonomous and self powered robot that
communicate and propel themselves
through the ocean while collecting oil
photovoltaic cells power the vehicle for
just 100 watts as the Nano
fabric-covered conveyor belt seamlessly
sucks up pollution while moving forward
using a swarm behavior the units
communicate via GPS and Wi-Fi to manage
their coordinates and ensure an even
distribution over the spill site by
detecting the edge of a spill and moving
inward a single vehicle can clean an
entire site autonomously or engage other
vehicles for faster cleaning
our calculation suggests that 5,000 see
storm vehicles operating continuously
for a month would be able to clean up an
area the size of the Gulf oil spill
so we were actually working the momentum
on the next prototype in the nonprofit
and not invited out just happen every
game but even when any time you go
through the water there's little skills
so we think that this type of different
approaches former pro shop little units
it's in spirits be a small speed of
response speed there keep on for using
the target war so so this is what we'll
do now now in developing the the next
version but these were two projects i
want to show because you know they
relate to people waste and pollution in
pain but i think there's something very
exciting that we can do is our face
unless i should be really not produce
ways in the first place I'm not
polluting the first place and i'll show
you a few examples of how we believe
that this new condition that combines
technology through technology changes
the interface between human and the
environment kanashii allow us to run our
cities in a much more efficient in
sustainable way in sorry if we go back
to the slides
so
the next module to show you something we
did last year at the Copa nadie UN
climate summit in December that's where
the kyoto protocol was being
renegotiated where all the heads of
state Obama all the heads of state from
all the world were trying to find an
agreement on on missions you know some
progress was made not as much as we all
hope and over there we were working with
the city for the summit the city who
came to us in just a couple of year
before years before and said you know
what how can we show the way ubiquitous
computing pervasive computing can change
it can increase sustainability so we all
did a trip to Copenhagen with a number
of students at MIT we been running a
workshop on the city and Mikey you know
one of the important interesting things
that you notice when you get there is
something like this you know there's a
Copenhagen is the city where they used
to head out of cars like in the seventh
is everybody to perfect our and then it
through taxation and through a number of
other things actually today over half of
all trips every day are done by bus so
it's quite impressive what you what you
see not very surprising especially when
you came from from an American city to
see this type of landscape so our view
was what can we do with the technology
and buys how could it is probation
welcome to the Copenhagen wheel the
wheel that turns your ordinary banging
into a smart electric hybrid quickly and
easily with no additional batteries or
wires the Copenhagen wheel allows you to
capture the energy dissipated while
braking in cycling and save it when you
need a bit of a boost control through
your smartphone the Copenhagen wheel
becomes a natural extension of your
everyday life the Copenhagen wheel is
your personal trainer sensing your
effort level and providing you with
real-time feedback about your fitness
and exercise goals the Copenhagen wheel
also enhances your experience with the
city it connects you with things that
cyclist wants to know upcoming traffic
congestion road conditions and pollution
levels choose to keep your data or share
it with your friends and other cyclists
through social networks like Facebook as
you ride you also collect Green Mile
it's similar to a frequent flyer program
the good for the environment elegant
responsive smart a new mode of transport
for rapidly changing world so turn on
your life and turn on the fitting the
Copenhagen wheel
the first prototype actually Ronnie and
the streets bye bye next year should be
in production so it should be available
by the end of next year commercially
available is it more detail you will so
basically here you break you get back
your energy and then you give it back to
you when you need if you want you can
also charge it so we can store like an
electrified and in the thing that
doesn't happen with most electric
bicycle at you can just read for 15 20
bucks you just take your bike change the
wheel or if you want just a hug and then
it becomes their you cancel electrified
so it's like your CDs become smaller you
can make it go faster further away if
you're even here the city like San
Francisco's become me like like a flat
city because when you're going downhill
you get back your energy when you're
going to appeal you get it back so it
becomes it makes the whole biking
experience more affordable it is
actually the mayor of copenhagen in
toronto destiny
Oh
I will follow
I said run away
Oh Dalton
this bike is fantastic that's incredible
good takes no effort you see my bike
you start pedaling and the motor takes
over and then if people tell you the ear
the temperature
bye
it's amazing to see like
well I do like it skip me a bitch
jumping from one project to another but
I just want to give you a sense of the
different direction where we believe
there's space for change and they got
one more project this more sustaining at
the scale of the city and then just wind
up something it's a bit more
architectural so this is actually
there's another direction where we think
there's a lot of efficiency to begin to
be gained incidence and that's when we
actually be able to understand cities
through all of those networks that have
been deployed in space it can be used as
the way to science the city is a kind of
viral sensing using all those networks
that are pervasive ubiquitous and allow
us to capture and describe the city in a
way that we couldn't do just you know
ten years ago as we did sir project the
first project on this topic we did with
Sarah Williams from out here we did it
couple years before in 2004 in Europe
but then it doesn't six we did before
the venice biennale in that year the
venice biennale the big exhibition about
architecture every two years in venice
2006 Ricky booth at the professor at the
London School of Economics was the
director in the team would it be neither
was the meta city it's about cities and
beta you know all about the cities and
the so Ricky gave us a pavilion that was
here in Sao ken can you show something
about how technology's changing cities
and transforming our knowledge of C so
this was our pavilion we had a number of
suspended screens and what we did there
was oops oh sorry our point is
i just installed the latest the latest
I was there yeah
yeah very sorry about it so so what we
decided to do it was in partnership with
Google and the main cell phone operator
in the country called telecom italia in
the city of Rome so we said well how
much information can we collect a real
time from the city and then we had all
the information from cell phones or the
information from the buses this was the
first time ever it's become a bit more
common now but it was the first time
ever did a very big city with several
million people was mapped by looking at
the traces of millions of people moving
in the city in an anonymous and
aggregated way and then we had all the
buses the tax is all this in real time
being transferred to a number of servers
it had been analyzed sent to MIT in then
sent back almost in real time to do
venice biennale when i say real time is
sometimes was a few seconds that they
have a second son as a few minutes but
sent back to the venice biennale
displayed in the pavilion do so before
so you know that summer we were very
lucky because it's this time it was four
years ago exactly and it's a summer day
italy won the World Cup the soccer world
cup and I'll show you here just a very
basic information what happened in the
city of Rome when the country the soccer
team won the world cup you know how
people moved and celebrated then looking
just at what happened on the cellphone
nitro that the day of the day Italy one
in the following day so here is the
video you can see the river the Coliseum
city center it's a normal day before the
match afternoon people movie here there
match begins silence France France
course eat ice cores halftime people
make a quick second half in the normal
time force overtime to a second overtime
in city on their head back and say it
anyways and then that night people went
to celebrate in the center you see the
big peak here the following day actually
going to be the prime minister in the
winning team here in the center and then
everybody moved here to a place called
chuka maximum where people celebrate
since Roman times is a big part in place
outdoor it didn't see the big P actually
comin up over there well you know this
is the basic information you can you can
get for the city from the cell phone
network but if you take this and you
apply artificial intelligence you can
really use this in order to make the
city work in a better way and they're
just a simple example does many more in
a lot of work we are doing in the in the
lab on this is that you know look at
this you see in right you see the
density of pedestrians and in yellow you
see tabs in taxes so the question here
was is there a good match between the
demand for public transportation as
pedestrians in the offer that's passes
over now how do we how do we do this
well I said before we had your real time
all of the data from the cell phone
network and if you look at the cell
phone night where we go something called
handovers and over is when you move from
one cell to another cell and then your
cell phone call your call has been
handed over when a person well if you
take all these hangovers all this is
anonymous and aggregated stop if you
take all of them and you look at them in
the city you gotta kind of let it flow
like a river that's moving in the city
and if you look at the river you can try
to see which part of the three breeds
cars and which part of the river is
pedestrians now the first idea you might
have is just look at the velocity or the
river it doesn't work in wrong because I
the pedestrians go faster than cops so
because there's so much traffic jam but
if you use a bit more artificial
intelligence you can actually detect
license in here you see it's quite good
the fact that you got the main railway
station people moving out and spreading
into the city any ideas you know is
there a good match between the buses the
offer of a green transportation demand
or public transportation and the moment
this has been used actually to redesign
some of the best lines in several cities
while we did the analysis but you know
think about the future not very far
where it's not any more like today today
we follow vassals so we need to adjust
as citizens to the schedule into the
line into the into the round to the
buses think about the future not very
far away where it's much more efficient
is actually buses follow me as these
buses following the needs of people need
to move from one place to another place
so completely dynamic in the
self-regulating system instead of a fix
and static system like we have today in
that something that you know we can
really do as architects together
engineers and sociologists and so to
change the way the city works in make it
much more efficient now to finish I want
to show it to a final projects of a
natural dimension we are trying to look
at you know the group has been growing
at MIT where we are now like 30 people
at MIT in pain in Singapore so we're
looking different dimensions we got four
subgroups in this space of how
technology changes the interface between
humans in space in the last one more
architecture because in Game you're
wearing school of architecture so want
to show you what what what type of
things we really could be become
possible this is because it crashes you
didn't say
so two final projects the first one is
in the first one is the first one in
siragusa at the world expo the world XO
that this year was in Shanghai two years
ago world in star goes on in the mayor
of the city very visionary person came
to us at MIT and said is there anything
we could do with the technology in water
now the interesting thing is that Spain
you know has this beautiful long
traditions tradition that goes back to
the art time respecting the middle ages
of using water in a very efficient
elegant architecture a stimulating way
so the question what can we do today
with technology to do something similar
with the same element with water in
space and the reason for water was at
the theme of the X 1080 was water so
this work expression was coming so we
had a class at MIT with the number of
people good Mitchell Dennis French on
record where we were teaching were
issued with me a number of students and
one of the ideas that emerged from the
class was you know can we actually use
kind of imagined fountains that use
quality digital water curtain it's not
very visible here but imagining at this
pipe with many many tabs that open and
close in opening closing they trade like
excellence made of water so you got this
program made of pixels and then these
tabs can do cuts basically drawn the
water in opening poses so you can draw
modified make it interactive yet it is
that the person who's jumping you know
the curtain can open up either jumping
and you know follow we can be like a
living curtain that you can use as a
material for defining space in public
space in this case so that was one of
the idea out of the class the nail liked
it very much the opposition party
in the in the city council said that's
because we felt like mouse you know
opening the water and building is very
well whatever the reason we got the
Commission to build to design if a
vendor at the entrance of the export and
this is what
you
from Sarah goes up to see and actually
the bidding was there but just when it's
down it just like a pool of water it's
actually designed in a way we did the
design with some landscape artists from
Paris called a John stay so design is
integrating the lone Boulevard so when
it's down it just started this long
Boulevard just okay like a big full of
water same size of the boulevard just so
what that was the design view thing
didn't build it what happen is they
naturally a few months later time
magazine named best project of the year
so we got the Commission just a few
months for the expert to get it this was
it this is a team we put together so a
Mikey our group big missions group then
his functions group our office in Italy
dance with architects in Paris just a
graphic designers in in Milan in OB
arrow in London in Madrid as engineers
the interesting thing is that to build
it as you know when you have a normal
building you usually have a main
contractor that's suppose doing the
concrete and the steel and then nigga
the subcontractor doing all the you know
electrical staff we know the digital
stuff when this case was so much control
staffs much digital stuff that the main
contractor was seen it so a company who
usually does automation in any
subcontracted all of the concrete and
steel and so on so we thought it was
interesting that the whole balance in
the building became the opposite of what
in normal ease you got the main
contractor doing the physical stuff in
the subcontractor with a digital stuff
it became almost killed until here is a
is an old picture just before the
opening hundreds one of the people from
the
testing the water I was being cut by the
system here was a guy when we also add
water here just you can have a very
light effect more more like rain it
looks like the poverty in brain it's
also fresh in the whole space so you
don't need air conditioning trag also
can be very hot that is great through
evaporative cooling we creates a very
cool Plaza over there you can add
projections so you can actually have
physical pixels the pixels made of water
with lightning so with additional layers
let them play if it was myself try not
to get wet enticed me the sensing now I
shouldn't tell you about the night when
all of the sensors collapse you know
they were probably running Windows and
Windows scratch like my like my
powerpoint now so but actually that
night was even more fun then I will give
more fun because the pavilion the
building we still make a lot of cuts
into the water and then it became
something different normally your
approach to pavilion and it opens up to
let you in but that night was all these
cuts it were done in a random way many
people i can jump without getting wet
and then all the kids from Sargasso you
find a lot of footage on YouTube don't
they taken that night and the following
night when going there just engaging
event in a different way and for us it
was very telling that you know as
architects or sociologists spanners we
always think about how people will use
and react with our buildings but then
reality is always surprising in this
case in a in a very interesting way and
the final project want to show is
something we're doing for the london
olympics 2012 started like a year ago
with an invitation from the mayor of
london he went to apparently went on a
tour of the Olympic site in an Olympic
site of the in Beijing was very
characterized with in Beijing Olympic we
can think about
the Savior and a new mayor of london for
joseph wasn't involved in the planning
of dueling dicks apparently he went to a
cig Olympic site and was a bit
disappointed well known very strong
landmark so he sent an email to 25 30
people around the world and say would
you participate in to a invited
confidential competition to design a new
symbol for the limpets something that he
described a kind of new eiffel tower for
london and because of Sir Gaza because
so I was one of the people invited so
this is the project we cannot be called
the cloud broadcasting the climate of
humanity again we put together a very
very big different team very
interdisciplinary team with engineers
are open slide in Germany with Google in
California with writer Umberto Eco in
Italy who gave us help us with initial
vision you know this is something you
couldn't do it here's what we work
really all together from all across the
world from Australia to north america
south america and europe in the today we
can do very easily thanks to again
placed in technology and then you know
we started working progeny we started
with this thinking about this british
obsession with whether you're when three
Englishmen meet they first talked about
whether the samuel johnson 1758 i know
that's a beautiful obsession with
weathered with clouds that goes back to
constable or goes back to the paintings
by turner maybe everything we started
looking at is about monuments of the
past you know what you do with it
somebody says could you design an eiffel
tower for the city especially for a city
like london well we'll des moines this
in the past and one thing you can one
train missing you can see is you know
gone
i er neither neither a human obsession
in the 3,000 years ago I want to go high
you could repair me 120 years ago you
can do an Eiffel Tower it was like every
week on up in the sky but what can we do
today that's you know less wasteful this
is light is there itself and then the
other thing is that the most successful
monuments of the past i read the
monuments that captured its aight guys
the spirit of the time so if you think
about 1851 the Crystal Palace is what
everybody considers that is the first
modern building you know the ISA server
architecture in dec was also the first
global expo ever in London capital of
the entire if you take the nest in
Beijing google building the stadium
that's a nice like the birth of the new
China it's really captured it sideways
they also find a very a bit disturbing
it's beautiful but it's easily
introverted it's in one looking it's
about control you know what we do that
says this sends a different message it's
not about top-down is about bottom line
it's about outward looking it's about
being distributed it's really in the end
about the people so the main idea for
the project was putting people on the
center stage but physically and you know
making them feel making each pass feel
like every day on well this type of
thing we can do today we couldn't do a
few years ago we got the materials we
got membranes this has been used now for
a number of years like PTFE that's the
water Cuban regime or this Eden Project
in Cornwall and then so the main view of
the cloud is three very thin powers like
needles into the sky and then the cloud
at the top the idea that people can go
up with around they go up and there is a
coming down through the elevator they
actually give them back their own energy
to power the cloud so part of the cloud
is powered by the people people going up
with a physical energy raising their
bodies bodies are coming down in the
same way as the elevator is as bright in
same way the toyota prius those brakes
will be generate energy
here is the entrance when you approach
your cloud is slightly secluded space at
the entrance and then you go up any on
the city starts open up next to you in
front of you you go up the ramp and then
you can ramp and our under the cloud you
enter inside the cloud and you know the
top of the ramp and then you can move
inside the different spheres we're
different we handle people system inside
the spheres on cyber spheres with
particles in the middle and moving
between one in the other some of them
fit some of them actually filled with
pot there and moving plea the idea is
that this would be an organically grown
structure so that I'll go premium this
for just you know has towers foundation
spheres foundations are not in special
the towers is actually something ash
like one of the engineers on the team
based in Germany develop for us it's
based on what we did it's based on what
we did in this tower in Stuttgart if you
remove the stairs that's a 50 meter
tower supported by 50 centimeter pole
Cecily like a needle the sky in the way
this works is that if you're an article
on engineer you go this tragedy that
tension works very well that compression
doesn't work well because of battery so
that's why you need columns are so thick
is so messy but then if you use a column
but you stabilizing the cable night then
you get around the problem Backman and
then you can get something that slender
compression the spheres are something
again some of the compression Spears lil
bit thicker imagine looking a bit light
particular sphere in Montreal some of
our thinner yeah tension Spears so like
watch like in self imagery is some of
them fraud freely floating around people
out there a very easy to assemble Bogut
our in the spheres eerily to grow what
Horizonte or to grow again soon as I was
saying before some of that while you
still need to get from photovoltaics so
you collect the energy use little
mirrors concentrating on photovoltaic
cells use the more efficiently and have
this kind of subdivision effect in order
to get to zero emission all the energy
you get is the energy consumed so the
whole plan is power in a renewable way
and the other energy energy of the
people people who grew up as I was
saying on drum and it coming down the
elevator will get back their own
potential energy in the cloud you will
feel yourself a magic is one kilowatt
hour walk up all the way up and give you
transform you into energy again because
the people who want this to be
determined in terms of size by the
people the fundraising or the cloud rain
thing is we say I think Obama showed all
of us for the first time that you know
it's no small change you feature fast as
a this is for contribution that can be
really a lot of change in the only way
we can address tomorrow's global
challenges anything from climate change
to co2 emissions is actually very able
to go from the digital space or the
self-organizing power of internet the
physical space over the past ten years
we the opposite we went through the
physical space back to the digital any
others for Cooper and everybody else but
today I'm going to the opposite view as
we go from
the digital and self organized in
promote physical change so this what
will i declare to be the first example
of a statute is still entirely in this
way one of the options we are exploring
is one pound one pixel so people can
make small donations to get a small
piece of the cloud perhaps show
themselves up there in the sky of London
in Google as a partner is a member of
the team offered to say every time
people in the one who doesn't work and
how to build a cloud is the first is a
first link that you get it just to
finish as the cloud is a real class the
real cloud is made of particles in those
particular water well our pad is made of
other particles of pixels pieces they
can show anything up in the sky of
London can show you what time of the day
I keys and can get all the real-time
information from the city and display up
there into the cloud so what's happening
in London what's happening John London
in the UK in all of Europe in all over
the world
an incredible thing will be how actually
them to move inside this cloud of pixels
moving like in a 3d screen to be able to
enter it and move in the middle of these
floating pieces that on the outside will
still you know share the main maybe
share the main Olympic moment with with
the whole city and the public so just
summarize both a physical cloud up in
sky of London a digital cloud with like
this to be also the torch you know the
torch of Atlanta uses match gases 10,000
people for three years i believe so can
we have the sustainable torch for the
olympics that just gets the energy needs
and you cannot become for the night in
london but more importantly a new type
of experience for london and everybody
we're going to have a brief round table
we'd like to invite the speakers to the
table and after that there's going to be
we're going to open it up to the floor
and if you stick around the reward will
be a reception which will be right
outside
I should introduce myself my name is
Austin like Dan and Jeremy i'm a beauty
student here at USF and also I'd like to
introduce moji Babu she's the head of
the fall faculty of the urban design
studio the semester and she's also been
curated into this ongoing series of the
public events about waste I think I'd
like to open it up with maybe a current
event with an open question we all voted
yesterday or at least my name is dick
was an election and in New York City we
were given the opportunity to vote for
the first time for a ballot initiative
whether or not private waste management
facilities should be mapped on the
public New York City citing that in
addition to what's already there which
is a publicly owned which facilities now
this is unprecedented because right now
nobody knows where these facilities are
they don't know how the trucks get to
where how they come out of the system
and and as a matter of fact it was voted
overwhelmingly to in fact make it
transparent so this issue of
transparency and visibility and mapping
reveals the issue of the mapping changes
not only the design of the city but also
the design of the citizen and in fact we
know corporations to this all the time
they're designing the consumer as
quickly as they are designing the
products so in this feature city how
does the role of citizenship itself
change i hope the participants of the
consumers and how how does that affect
the changes and the relationships
between us and society politics
it's a really compelling point about how
I mean of course as the city changes and
as our knowledge of like where transfer
stations are I'm sorry as we learn about
those things our behavior does change
and the way in is through space changes
and what we consume changes
I i'll try i'll try to you start with
data data data is is a crucial thing
today and data can be really a very
empowering thing actually since last
year data.gov in this country with the
Obama administration couple of years ago
in similar initiatives that are
happening all across the planet even in
cities landon wheatland we are working
with this initiative that's what they're
working a margin involved that's let's
open up all the city data in sharing
data citizens so that can be can really
be empowering imagine you know all this
wealth of information is shared with
everybody the other interesting thing is
that this amount of information we are
collecting is growing exponentially you
know we collected as much information
from the beginning of civilization v
2003 as we collected from 2000 and 30
2010 so the amount of information we're
collecting today is growing incredible
way and so all of that has potentially a
very empowering as kicking can be using
incredibly empowering way by sharing
with citizens it is also something we
can look at very carefully let me make
an example this is one again unintended
consequences of the digital revolution
nobody be anticipating if you go back to
nicholas eng apologies
in digital 1995 or brought the books at
the beginning of a dream you thought
about it but the point is that if you've
got something to save digitally then you
got something that's searchable in a
dozen decade so today we are leaving
signals of digital fingerprints in those
fingerprints in that somewhere and then
it can be searched and we publish the
day forever if you think about the most
innocent thing you could do is taking a
picture well nobody ever thought that a
beneficiary in the past was a problem so
you take a picture in a pipe with space
in a private space that picture will be
printed from be on paper it will end up
in a drawer in your grandmother's drawer
in the natural few decades with BK in
the body you know we'll find anymore so
pray now today everybody's taking
pictures all the pictures are gone on to
data sets of the figure on facebook on
to other databases some of them are
searchable can be indexed and then he
becomes it can become a problem you
might know that Switzerland is the first
country that banned the google car
because he thought was an invasion of
privacy either he was actually first guy
to where it was an accident because some
value was there with an illegal lover in
the Google car arrived and then the
other person was so concerned that might
end up on the internet capture on the
Internet forever with this a big
elaborate was the hit by a car while
running away so I mean that becomes a
problem in fact that that you know
digital information is searchable in
thousand decade so here it is a very
good condition for Humanity in certain
sense it's a very condition because one
of the very important mechanism be used
in the past we have developed if an
evolutionary way is forgetting some
stuff we want to move on and how do you
move on if you cannot forget anything
more because everything is down there
you know everything is being recorded
and you can be accessed it is
you install this finger bits are there
now so there's this huge amount of data
and it's a new condition and this is
potentially a very very interesting
Democratic resource on the other hand
would you need to open it up so the big
battle today it's about that we all
should be involved is really how should
this data be managed you know in what is
mentioning yesterday goes in a very
positive way goes in the way of open it
up making it accessible to everybody in
using this data to improve everybody's
life but this big forces the goes in the
other direction and it's a big question
that's on the table today in order to
contribute to it we had a forum last
year at MIT called we organized forum
called engaging data with privacy
advocates the Obama administration big
companies like AT&T google web wife
managed lot of data academics really
because it's a big question on the table
in solution will look at together and I
think you know voting for the opening up
of data in sharing this with the
community I think is the way to go but
we need many more votes by the one you
mentioned yesterday I'd like to ask moji
the question as head of the false studio
in the light of this idea of the shaping
of citizenry and how everything is
exponentially growing every single day
what is the unique contribution that
designers particularly that's at school
and then when we into the professional
arena what role do you think we can
serve as everything's changing so
quickly in the shape
this is a challenge for all of us that
try to construct studios and go through
the process of educating the future
generation and estopa how do we keep up
and how do we introduce the
infrastructure the system or ways of
thinking beyond just learning how to use
the technology to keep up with this very
rapid change also it's the question of
how do we organize and design in fact
the implementation of our ideas Heather
earlier on also talked about that what
are the systems we can put in place or
as part of our design and the strategy
get engaged with and how do we teach
that in this in our studios when we have
small group of research studios focus
lab etc I think similar to harness team
maybe we can move much faster and more
focused and when we have large group of
students we have 50 / 50 students in our
urban design program the challenge
becomes very interesting in a way
because we do want to use the scale that
we have at the same time we need to
introduce methodologies technology
layering understanding how the
complexities can be collectively help
for us to put what we do is in a larger
context versus isolating guillotine
point of view in order to produce
project so we have a team of faculty
having large team of students we also
can offer a team of faculty with
expertise from many areas as
mention this is becoming extremely
critical these days we have to have
expertise to comment collectively for us
to question these some of these topics
and aggressive so we're really quite
fortunate to be able to do this year
come here and we definitely need to do
it more in this semester which is a
regional scale it also gives us
opportunity to look at actually are we
gently carefully so we try to work with
communities and organizations in a very
direct manner and gravely data or
information from the communities
directly into the studio but also we are
beginning to discuss how to isolate
different scales of operation and in
fact other than designing to take over
and discuss as designers we need to take
over and discuss but open design this
gives us another tool to really do it
which again the presentation tonight I
think it rests very well small career
relatively small community that takes on
the challenge of leaving environmentally
responsible and going through the
process of how do you make that actually
happen how do you implement
so all the social cultural dimensions
that I think both of our speakers talked
about comes in and we try to bring it
for student studios as well to looking
at systems and discussions that in fact
have a much broader impact but
ultimately comes down to designing one
unit how do you take that so for us it's
a question of designing how to design
and how do we communicate and positive
how do we use all and then how do we
communicate so the students take charge
of the gang on how to design we would
like very much to create a discussion of
the implementation to our studios we are
hoping that this type of responsibility
we would like to in bringing to our
Studios can be carried out as
professionals also so this is struggling
to figure out how to do it I want to
pick up on this idea of systems because
i think what both presentations have
common is the IDF serious process on the
one hand gets feedback loop
private which is the whole point is that
there's no one policy right there's no
one project device is an ongoing process
so so for this new kind of cities
process what are the you know what might
be like the new infrastructures right
like so all of a sudden a cell phone
network is an integral part of the
infrastructural underlayer of a city but
the cell phone was that you know when it
was popularized the late nineties so
even that is changing right now we have
all sorts of new technologies what might
be the new kind of infrastructure for a
city of process or in fact does the city
has process negate the necessity for
large-scale investment you'll probably
answer this quite differently I mean I
sort of carla's really engaged in what
what's coming you know and you're really
doing an innovative stuff and an
assassin by the way what and and what I
do is really look at what's happening
now and the in terms of infrastructure I
think it's crucial you have to have you
have to have a social infrastructure not
just a physical infrastructure but you
need a physical infrastructure to you
know and and one of the things that that
I see happening in the United States is
there's a lot of this gets politics in
the social infrastructure there's a lot
of lip service being paid to
stability but not a lot of actual
infrastructure being built and we need
that we need solar panels we need wind
turbines me you know the kind of
physical infrastructure and there's you
know the kind of thing that's happening
in Freiburg you know it shows it shows
that you you when you have those things
you can actually you know you can use
them and you can achieve these goals one
of the things that happens with
political you know when we look at what
are the barriers I mean essentially in
Freiburg we have the technology we need
it's not being implemented in the United
States as much as it could be and some
of the reasons I've found is that it's
not as profitable as the way things are
done you know in a more wasteful
polluting way so the barriers then
become economic in terms of you know the
economic order of things and then also
political so it often comes down to
people saying well it's just a lack of
political will what is political will
you know and there's a role in that a
big component of that is public well and
so how do you start you know redesigning
cities to generate a different kind of
public well you know and so that it's
not such an emphasis on the individual
you know there's there's more of an
emphasis on how we work together and
that not we do and must work together
and a place like fiber does that if
together people together in New in
different ways actually surprisingly
advanced for exactly the same way I
would say you know the new
infrastructure the cities is the people
or just wait why to waste lands for this
place and what is the people or there's
no infrastructure we think the
infrastructure a very term is about a
thing you think about you know all of
these systems that are heavy systems in
order to support life into supporting
city or urban whatever you want movement
or urban life now the interesting thing
is that a lot of the systems belong to
the whole century the all century
decentralized is top-down is something
that's done you know in a controlled way
now today we can do a lot of those
things not all of them but most of them
you can do them in a different way in a
bottom-up way in a wetland powers
between a crowdsourcing way you know we
can really think about an infrastructure
it becomes distributed began if you want
becomes the people if you want really
disappears so in adding there's many
examples that we actually work in rio de
janeiro in in the favelas for a project
for the olympics with General Electric
in the idea is how we can actually
create a new water infrastructure with a
bottom-up approach with people actually
collecting purified air or water locally
and sharing it and creating a kind of
system that allowed in a certain sense
infra statues about organization and
that you don't need top-down
organization once you came and self
organized so that's when people become
crucial and when you know you don't need
that old fogey century top-down stuff
just quickly the distribution like you
know the decentralization of the car was
talking about community again you see
that in freiburg but the power station
that they have the cogeneration facility
is not you know that that model is one
it is necessarily decentralized and then
also the building that I showed you that
has its own power plant in the building
I mean that's that's nothing new you
know that's been happening since the
beginning of so it's not even
necessarily doing something that's never
been done before but it's doing things
that have been done for a very long time
in a more may be self-conscious way or
you know history is a big part of moving
forward to just to follow a little bit
of this question of infrastructure
question have you emulation door studios
in teaching profession generally
speaking in our urban design studios we
try to define what's there and what's
not
design project this semester the topic
is wasted wasted so we literally start
from the bottom of the gutter well which
had break it down right now to looking
at where and so we're all over the map
efficiencies are huge the lack of
infrastructure I'm wondering if you have
any suggestions and both of you are in
the business of looking at information
and arranging
that is understandable but also you
collect and find ways to get also you
give it a spatial form which as a
redesigned program again we really are
committed to bringing the projects to a
level of actual human space so it's very
important for us to figure out as a
faculty how do we design the
infrastructure infrastructure
in or wasted yeah oh not even talk about
what is efficient about that's the
problem is for it's easier to this
obviously as you mentioned there is a
lot of usage of materials we just have
to use in this economy of broke you
continuously apply and in one of the
earlier lectures you gave us you talked
about how it's embedded in the
manufacturing industrial economy to
inside for us to continuously used and
the consumers are in fact train which
changes when you move into the digital I
mean they just build upon of the last
one that's what is very interesting is
about your consumerism in a digital
world and you know it won't be
wonderfully young what happens it if you
go back to thurston baglan who first
wrote about conspicuous consumption you
know why how we use consumption is a way
to be furnished make ourselves different
than show different things about
ourselves to the others well it would be
great if you actually could take the
same mechanism but turn into something
that's not wasteful so you know if you
throw away eat that you don't need
anymore to waste one washing machine per
year or whatever but you can do that
just with bits you know you're not
polluting you're not using very little
energy you you can just do that a lot of
that in in the digital space in the
thing that is happening actually it's
happening is very interesting very good
news is the fact that people in Japan
don't like ours anymore and you know but
they wouldn't buy little things and we
use the conspicuous consumption
mechanism is something that seems to be
quite embedded in the DNA
you know pipeline and all the others
trace it back to two very deep roots so
maybe we cannot eradicate that but you
can actually just do something that
instead of keeping or consuming all
these physical stuff all of these atoms
we can just turn it into bit and then
it's it's still works but it's much
better for the environment for all them
so like that well the weights you know I
mean can you can you use actually your
Facebook page can you use stuff it's
online can use the music you listen to
you need to buy a Ferrari anymore but
you graduate so do the same use the same
mechanism to through digital information
that you show in you share with the
community so can you actually go from
physical consumption to digital
consumption and I think that's a very
good challenge and the thing that's a
great challenge for architects nor can
we actually promote this can actually
ourself design system that allow the
same mechanism happen in a vest waste
boom what yeah and I mean I guess I have
the like analog Corp correlation to that
which is just that like redefining what
is consumption you know and what is it
because I think a lot of people when
they talk about environmental stuff and
I like don't consume
we're just we're greedy and we want
everything now and you know and this
kind of thing and that's just human
nature and there are some aspects of
that that are part of human nature I
mean we do we do have desire and and we
do have you know sensual we seek sensual
gratification and things like that and
but there are so many ways that we can
you know meet those needs and desires
and I think it's so important to you
know to value that and I just think it's
so often it gets that all of that like
the baby gets thrown out with the
bathwater when you're talking about
reducing consumption and more
efficiencies and conservation things
like that there's so there's so much I
can't remember if I talked about this
the first time when I sub last time but
you know I think there's a lot of ways
that that we can start to pull apart you
know growth which is like our standard
of living and our well-being currently
is defined based on the growth of our
economy and what our economy isn't
growing as is happening right now
people's quality of life their
livelihoods decrease and I think that it
could be really useful to pull apart two
separate outgrowth from development I
could call development or you know kind
of livelihood that we have I think that
we can have a very good standard of
living in an in an economy that that
isn't predicated on growth the kind of
growth that we have right now and in
doing that I think could open up a lot
of room to you know create new kinds of
satisfaction without the destruction
that so often comes along with
I think at this point we'd like to open
the discussion up to the audience but it
will have some questions
Levi now Michael Keenan yit and first I
want to thank you for the great
discussion before it was like very
informative I have a to question my
first question is about the technology
and the waist and my question I want to
be more specific I want to ask you about
do you think that the new technology of
transforming waste into the alternative
fuel will have a big impact on the city
and that's like I'm talking about a
waste gasification or the plastic
turning in crude oh and my second
question is about the echo the echo City
which was in Freiburg I'm very
interesting in the bottom of approach
and I would like to if you can elaborate
a little bit more on is what about the
bottom-up approach and when exactly this
professional planners come into onto the
table when do they when they are like
becoming a part of this community based
development and approach and I went also
the city join the community but the
community board
on on new technologies 44 waist there's
very interesting developments I think
one of the most promising one is plasma
you know when when you burn this this
plastic bottle and by the way you
shouldn't have plastic bottles of you
don't only one a panel and waste here
but if you burn this plastic bottle
there's a lot of molecules that gets
produced in a lot of them are toxic in
their toxic because our complex
molecules in the our body doesn't
interface very nicely with it now if you
burn it however very high temperature in
plasma you reach plasma level then at
that level all of the molecules break
down into atoms and then you get the
elemental the individual atoms out out
of the process and if you do that you
get something that is the best way to
treat it's used today to treat a lot of
very polluting very toxic waste but that
tomorrow might become much more common
it may be a very interesting wait we're
very small plants really perhaps in the
neighborhood level at home level that
really allow you to process waste
without any toxic gas or emissions or in
selective freezes plasma is suddenly
very interesting that's being
investigated there's a lot of research
on it there's initial plans working and
that's this one of them there's many
address so I think the answer is yes
however i think you know again i don't
think that the solution is coming from
an approach that the old approach is the
20th century approach of you big
infrastructure think a lot of the
solutions coming from changing our
behavior in organ
ourself in order being in easy is this
software approach instead of the hard
infrastructure approaches about self
organizing is about changing our
behavior is about some of the things
that we saw in in Freiburg so the short
answer is yes it's very interesting new
technologies coming up but I think we
should focus more on the other side it's
you know the bottom of self-organized
inside the process in freiburg that that
the community went through was they they
formed this organization formed Obama
pretty early on and they got money from
the government from the federal
government to create a plan and as they
were doing that from what I understand
they consulted with professional
planners but really the community you
know played the biggest role in coming
up with this plan you've got you've got
people who are physicists engineers
biologists architects involved in this
process so they there already I mean
they are professionals in terms of
having a knowledge base to do this they
have worked at the the city you know in
various capacities on and off through
you know for the last 15 years so it's
you know it's very much a give-and-take
process and
right yeah I mean there's different
times like when they first started
establishing fo bomb the Mayor was
totally opposed to it and they found
there were a couple Green Party council
members that they really liked
cultivated and words to win over and
they did and the city when they first
agreed to sell them to of the bunker
buildings I mean the barrack buildings
at the last minute the city got cold
feet and and they were saying you know
actually you know we said we'd sell it
to you but we're not sure because they
did kind of want to just you know sell
it to commercial developers and just
carry on as they have been doing because
I mean taking on something like this was
a big a huge unknown and what they did
was they the people in foreign boba
which is just then forming they moved
into the buildings and they said you
know you said you were going to sell
them so where you are going to sell them
you know so they had to pressure in that
way another thing that is interesting to
compare the other neighborhood and
freiburg weasel felt reason felt is a
top-down eco community so the city came
in and again it was municipal land the
city came in it was actually the sewage
dumping site this is fascinating it was
the sewage dumping site and the name
weasel felled means like sewer field and
they didn't change the name but anyway
so they r ezel felt has can you imagine
saying i live in sewer field just i live
in this
anyway um so they there's 10,000 people
living there so its bigger and I met the
guy who planned it and he is like you
know just a total egomaniac of course
you know it's like this was my hears
about to retire and he was just like
this is my you know great creation like
and you know as a result it's not as
dynamic of the place and people you know
I met people who live there i met a
truck driver and his family and i met a
guy who dismiss an accountant and i met
a teacher you know and and that place is
much more of just like a place to live
you know it's not as much of a community
and there's a lot more cars and it's you
know there's a lot there's a lot less of
a drive to to pay close attention to
what happens on a day-to-day level on a
social level economic you know
environmental so i think that's an
interesting comparison and if there's a
kind of rivalry between the two I could
follow up really quickly um I remember
your first lecture we talked a little
bit about the stigma of trash and when
that switch happened when the rag
pickers are accepted in New York and
then when it became you know you don't
even want to retain your trash bin
sometimes so um I'm just curious in all
of our research and field trips looked
at ways to energy and there's such a
stigma no matter how many facts can be
talented as to how clean it might be
once there is rubys it's interesting to
observe that this uses biomass in
and I'm just wondering in your
estimation it that's more acceptable to
the community rather than burning
something that we be more is trash we
think of burning wood you know it's the
fireplace it's not you know your night
burning the trash that you would
normally throw out there is a mindset
that feels that's more easy to accept
the burning of the wood chip and it
would be waste waste well you know I
just want to follow because Germany is
one of the countries that is very
advanced to waste our energy and they do
have it in small communities in larger
cities they built many keys around these
plants and because the communities
directed benefit from it it's actually
quite popular if there's a discussion
now that is also it's quite clean again
it's fascinating because like you have
in developing countries you have
development projects coming in and
saying you know these people are burning
they have these like wood-fired cook
stoves and you need to like get them gas
or whatever and then and then now
suddenly burning wood is is
environmentally
also like this whole thing about the
plasma I mean I think that's you know
that's important but that you if you can
really get rid of toxics getting energy
getting energy from burning materials I
mean the first incinerators were
waste-to-energy a lot of people you know
think that that's a new thing but it's
not there's a lot um my question sort of
about like crowdsourcing and behavioral
mapping and I guess like active
participation versus like passive and do
you see like they're being like a
tipping point as to the amount of
information or sources people can
actually interface with and you see it
as an evolving thing like people are
able to interact with and contribute to
a wider array of data now or you know
ongoing as they were to in the past
studies they've done
yeah well I probably to look at
collecting data in the using data so
it's two different things i'm collecting
data I'm not sharing this data as you
say you're some of that is passive in
the sense that you know we just by doing
what we are doing we are leaving traces
and contributors data is going somewhere
some of that exactly we actively upload
somebody's data that's all the
phenomenon to some people called little
video sisters shall be brother the fact
that you know everybody's frosty is
tweeting about 9pm taking a shower is my
pictures on who cares but anyway all
these massive informations will
accumulate accumulate in bed say you
know some kind of bottom-up monitoring
in sharing data and so over there I
don't see you know in soon a certain
sense that's going I believe that that's
going to continue because networks have
been deployed sensors are becoming
cheaper and cheaper you know I can put
them up the trash is in people can you
know keep on sharing more and more the
data they have so that's on the on the
collection side of the contribute inside
now the question then is that once you
go this huge massive information as we
said before in seven years we build as
much information as we build from
beginner civilization to 2003 in st.
dozen 2010 then you know how do you
slice it what do you do with it how do
you use it beyond that then the
interesting question and that's where I
gave is architects designers geologists
and so we can play vpro you know how you
make sense of it there's so much stuff
that you can you can combine and
together so so that's really dating the
crucial question and there's issues of
visualization visualization is a way to
make it accessible in an easy way
because the visualization is also
something that needs to be done in a
very careful way it's very political you
know by visualizing your business so
much stuff you need to make a decision
what you're visualizing when you're not
visualizing by doing that you're certain
creating a bias you yo-yo you're just
make your own decision about you know
how you represent the world so it's
something that needs to be done very
carefully and there's huge potential
also in from this sociology bonertube in
what people started calling
computational social sciences that's the
title of an article in science magazine
in a year ago more less really the fact
that sociology traditionally yeah sure
you know it's just called like a science
but you know you if you think your
science is some people you have a lot of
numbers out of experiments a lot of data
you can really use social sciences call
the cell sciences but the young were not
using exactly the scientific today for
the first time we can actually have this
huge amount today that we can use to
analyze problems in the social science
is the same way with analyze problems in
physics or
Adam power sciences you know it's and
this is the year of computations of
Social Sciences dal can waltz Atticus
here at Columbia was a very good sushi
ologist who initially brought with
Steven sprockets that paper called the
small world in nature you know he's one
key people in this field this is angry
is going to do because of automatic that
you can be half so baby in a nutshell
we've got this huge amount of data and
then we can use it to describe life in a
better way make better models economics
avoid prices because prices and bubbles
because we can describe reality even
much more fun great so we separate in
the collection a huge amount of data is
going to be collected passive or active
so that's going to continue the crucial
questions are how you then you take this
mask and make sense out of it I will be
visualizing away analyzing and I ask who
cares when you tracked the garbage what
do you use that information for well
what is in it in the same ways when you
you know we're saying when you've got to
hospital they put the trace in your
blood and you follow it you understand
the metabolism of the body in things you
know where you got a problem in the case
of trash you try to do the same in the
scale of the city so one of the
questions you can ask and we are asking
it's still in progress the papers are
about to come out but one on one of the
question is you know can you actually
remove it more efficiently so put less
energy in moving all this stuff you saw
that of those three thousand pieces of
crunch how some of them went from
Seattle to Florida California I mean the
moon roll across the United States
especially when you look at this will
carry me we're showing you the beginning
as well especially when you can eat
waste or special ways no it musli lot so
the first question you can ask can you
actually have a more efficient way but
moving on the stuff is a huge amount of
energy that goes the other question you
can ask is you know is it always
beneficial to recycle because sometimes
you put more energy than what you get it
in the end so you could take a in old
printer cartridge and you move it all
the way from Seattle to Florida a you
know by the time you move all that in
DeAngelis is probably better to have a
small plasma plant and pin seattle and
just get rid of it there instead of
moving it all the way down there and
then ship it somewhere else so there
that's another question so they did in
it does assemble them but the bottom
line is can you really streamline the
process that at the moment is hasn't
been designed yes three mind why can you
make it more efficient and less wasteful
see this is something about design that
I often have questions about because I
think design is very important
oh really everybody's used to it it's a
design flaw um but it is that okay a big
part of it is design but also you know
the reason that the printer cartridge
goes from Seattle to Florida isn't
because they just don't realize that
it's inefficient it's because there
there's a certain logic at work and that
logic within that logic it is efficient
to send the printer cartridge to Florida
so it's not just a matter of looking at
okay wait we're sending this down here
and we could be doing its more
efficiently you know like the number of
strawberries that are exported from
California is exactly equivalent to the
number of strawberries that are imported
into California you know that that's an
obvious ridiculous and efficiency but it
happens because of you know the economic
logic so you know is the problem that we
don't really know we don't really know
the right design I mean or is I mean
there's other things at play there's
certainly address the things that place
oh so you're right there's economic
logics there's there's other things in
play but there's also a big design
component in design component is the fat
you know how many subcontractors you
have a and also when you understand the
deficiencies then you can actually
promote there's two ways to practice the
design of the system in one way to
implement across is into legislation
mean you can then make you know you can
they have incentives in order to freezes
to make it more convenient to keep the
strawberries in California and you know
eat the California shoppers SS Endon way
in getting a dress into the country
including to the state so what I mean is
that there is still an issue of design
that could be implemented in many ways
in simple ways that in the case of dash
track we've been working with waste
management one of the largest waste
management companies in in the world
actually we had to do the project and
we're a university labs were interested
in research and we we were asking people
they wanted to collaborate with us to
develop it and deployed and say sure you
know because if you would like to learn
more about what's happening we did do
some of the stream and they move some of
the waste but they don't know the whole
story inside it's very interesting once
you know it they put themself make
changes so what I mean is that it's
always the design question and sometimes
the changes could be implemented in the
local level sometimes you might need a
political intervention but we still have
an impact if we can just add something
specially in relation to our studio here
as educators we believe on making
knowledge available so information and
making information organized in a matter
that is useful in this part of our
knowledge base is very important in
terms of our studio we use this question
to decide what is the impact or
lifestyle so being a regional studio
allowed us to in fact question what is
the region of our impact in other words
if my e-waste goes to Ghana is my
regional impact
fact needs to be drawn understood which
brings you the discussion of what is our
responsibility as designers to
understand not only just part of
producing what they extend and again
it's discussion of practice and
profession how do we organize ourselves
within this to you so that this
discussion we are interested in
discussing students um there I don't
question should he take them um I was
thinking we could wrap up in here I
didn't know if Heather Carla had a brief
concluding thought and then we can move
out to the reception ladies come feel
freeze it good question wrong and then
hopefully this will lead to a conclusion
but we had an interesting conversation
last week about economy and there's a
lot of data out there and you know some
some of the irony of making things more
efficient as as heather was saying at
the beginning is what we could be more
efficient at destroying our planet and
so we could do things efficiently and
consume more and more I forget which
paradox but you're saying something of
that as we make things more efficient
we're actually for the more energy to
say the more you actually use you know
we're doing more efficiency whatever
that you're just consuming more up and
so we're producing more and more and
more so you're pointing out the
underpinnings of how the economy works
and how we view our economies and one of
the one of the things we were talking
about last week was gross domestic gross
domestic product and I'm just wondering
you know in this age where we have all
these nations are being measured by
their GDP and their growth and profit
and how much that the witness system or
the models that we use to measure is
actually fueling the increase in
kinds of the consumption that we see
this increase in the amount of ways so
I'm wondering and that question came up
are there other models of how we view
this data or how we look at economy
economies that would lend themselves
more to reduction of consumption waste
because it seems like some of this stuff
that you're modeling like coming up with
different ways of measuring you know it
seems like that can start to get at what
this question is I mean there are people
now measuring gross domestic happiness
and you know these kinds of questions
and the cracks me up because people talk
about measuring gross domestic happiness
and the one country that does that is
bhutan and it's a monarchy everybody's
really happy but anyway so the yeah I
mean there's so many ways to measure it
and GDP is a very narrow and misleading
measurement for a lot of people and it's
it's very specific and very accurate for
measuring as a measurement for
corporations and you know the kind of
neoliberal economics that have
prevailed in recent decades but you know
there this is part of what we need to
remake and it's something that the
people in gabon are remaking which is
how do we how do we you know gauge what
we do as a success or a failure what is
it kind of gets back to the point that I
was making before about you know how do
you how do you define growth and how do
you define success how do you define you
know even happiness anymore totally
obsessed with happiness in this society
how do you how do you define freedom and
choice all these really important
components of our society that we value
a lot and like you know the question of
choice when you tell people that we need
to consume less because we do that's how
that's how we're going to cut our co2
emissions that's how we're going to you
know mitigate the kind of damage that's
already being done with the loss of the
ice sheets and the glaciers and the
social and environmental impacts that is
you know we need to produce less co2 we
need to Falu bucks we need to produce
less garbage and it's not something that
we are just going to do as individuals
because we need to have those choices
and we don't have those choices right
now we don't have enough of those
choices and when when I say that I often
hear you know this kind of response that
well you know if you if you tell us that
we can't consume as much
we're going to suffer our comfort level
will go down and our standard of living
will go down and and one thing that I
noticed in doing a different research
that I've done is that you know if you
look at the choices that we have now
under you know the kind of free choice
that that we're supposed to be getting
is you know something like ninety
percent of the food we eat contains corn
that's a massive elimination of choice
you know the the dying species on the
planet are a massive elimination of
choice if you could you know define it
in different ways so there's a there's a
huge elimination of choice that is the
result of measuring you know GDP and
having an economy in a political system
that works the way ours does and that
values certain social status or you know
social standing the way that ours does
and that is something that we can change
as you just have all things very quickly
let's say well I want to go back to what
head were saying before about the growth
and development and you know GDP
measures growth but development I say
something that we make our place happy
so as happy tonight because in the end
if thing about development what the only
thing about development is the interface
between us people in the environment
that's you know that's what changes were
what were praised development in
redesigning the interface is that
interface the gate redesign you change
when when man first stop learn south of
agriculture and second Stan in den seven
thousand years ago in city FC is
appeared they didn't exist before and in
they appear in dancing on redesigning
the interface and bringing people
together making them more social and
public in creating many other things so
in the end really the real progress in
science is the one we can do by rick is
an interface between us and outside
environment so that's a that's our role
of architects designers and planners and
just finally to my fun parties in the
same way as many of our projects use
crowdsourcing will you believe in it
safe in diffuse interesting contributing
or being involved also send us an email
there's on the website there's all the
contacts and you'll be great to get
comments feedback or involved thanks i
just want to thank everybody for coming
and maybe we can continue this
conversation outside thank you